[Applause]
you know the part of what makes villain
fight so amazing is the hype the one
moment that makes you question a hero's
hopes for defeating his arch nemesis one
day honestly speaking i feel that in
shown in anime a lot of that hype is
generated by a villain showing off his
power a mighty showcase of power a flex
if you will it's one of the most
effective ways of building up the wall
that you want your hero to eventually
overcome so with that said we'll be
spending today's list talking about some
moments where the villains flex their
powers on the good guys i won't be
counting down this time because how can
i rank these moments that are all as
epic and despair inducing i told you any
longer so let's get the show on the road
oh remember eisen casually stopping
ichigo with a finger i do and it's the
impetus for an amazing climax of what
many believe to be bleach's finest ark
just after a gruelling battle with
byakuya ichigo's completely spent as a
final obstacle in his quest to rescue
rookier he has to get over aizem the
same eizen who by the way already
one-shotted hitsugaya and defeated ranji
prior to that now within brandishing his
new nifty bankai to do a combination
attack with the barely alive renji
ichigo seems to do protagonist stuff and
slash his way to a happy ending the
setup's there the music's there so here
we go only the music
stopped with one finger eisen stops
ichigo's attack and he effortlessly
beats him and renji if the difference in
power wasn't obvious before well it sure
is now and to add to the flexing eisen
also effortlessly defeats another
captain who comes after him fun fact
eisen so powerful that this is the last
time the vocal version of ichigo's theme
plays in the anime you hear multiple
remixes of it but for the original
version of number one this was it
muzan casually creating a demon has to
be on this list as well
[Music]
it may not be anywhere near the moment
that allowed demon slayer's popularity
to shoot through the moon but early on
tanjiro has a pretty interesting
encounter with muzan still in that
famous michael jackson form that he's
long since abandoned they encounter each
other on a crowded street and a lot of
us hold our breaths thinking that the
confrontation is near only it never
happened when muzan created a demon out
of a passive eye to cause mayhem now
this is pretty interesting as in
contrast to the usual flexing it's not a
show of strength however it's a display
of how on top of the situation muzan is
and how easily he could spawn an army of
monsters to do his bidding he merely
sees danjiro as nothing more than a pest
at this point and this is as clear as a
warning as he can give it's just a
preview of the strength he holds
remember he stands above the upper moons
and if the pillars are already having so
much trouble with the moons who knows
what muzan has in store for our
protagonists the final showdown against
him will be a thing to look out for
we continue with a classic yuuyu hakusho
moment remember toguro destroying the
construction site
yes i do remember that moment among the
major villains in yu yu hakusho goguro
already had quite the intimidating
presence i mean just look at this guy a
humongous beast of a demon who'd
probably had muscles for days and who'd
be enough to send people packing but to
further drive the point home he
completely levels the entire
construction site not with magical
powers or anything like that but just
his fists his bare fists and how much
power of this did he use to accomplish
the humongous street 60
yes a little over half of what he's
capable of and that's the result that we
got from it we let the destruction speak
for itself really i really like this
moment because it builds up the hype for
their eventual showdown so much now if
that's what doguro is capable with just
a little over half of his power how
could yusuke even have a chance he's a
dead man and it's going to take
everything for him to even stand a
sliver of a chance against this opponent
now for a less popular one i bring you
pandora showing off her might
shown in anime is rife with big villains
flexing on the good guys so i won't
blame you if pandora wasn't the first
character to come to your mind when you
first clicked this video but her feat in
the re zero flashback arc is no small
one wanna talk about the most broken
ability in anime well maybe rewriting
reality is a contender but pandora is
more than happy to show it off in her
battle in amelia's flashback fortuna and
goose tried to stop her but they can
only do so much despite goose's act of
sacrifice which slowly opened up the
path for him to become the better goose
that we all know from season one they're
all no match for the witch of vainglory
who seems to be content on toying with
them none of these small fries stand a
chance against her and it takes emilia
and the plot to finally put an end to
her run temporarily
how's that for a first half of the list
before we keep going though i'd like to
introduce you to today's sponsor
expressvpn now a lot of you may have
heard of vpns and what they do but have
you ever run into the problem of picking
the right one i'm here to simplify
things for you by introducing you to my
pick expressvpn's been my friend for who
knows how long it's the easiest to use
and the most effective one out there
when i traveled the world and didn't
want to miss a beat in following my
weekly anime expressvpn it was always
there for me i recently used it to watch
some killer kill fights just open
expressvpn and select the united states
server and boom now you can use it to
watch hundreds of different anime which
aren't available in your region your
data and online privacy is also safe and
this is especially important in
countries with more stringent rules on
online activities if you're interested
then don't forget to click on
www.expressvpn.com
vinnietube or follow my link in the
description box with such a cheap
starting price for the comfort you'll be
getting you aren't gonna find a better
deal elsewhere now back to the show if
there's a beatdown that luffy wouldn't
be forgetting anytime soon it's the one
he suffered at the hands of crocodile
it's a harrowing sight that i still
remember vividly to this day luffy's
first battle against crocodile is as
ill-fated as it could possibly be
despite all the bravado he displayed in
front of vivi the battle seems skewed
towards luffy at first with our hero
being a house of fire in unloading
attacks on the master of sand however
the momentum doesn't last long as it's
pretty obvious that as the battle rages
on crocodiles completely in control he
might not be landing hits on luffy but
in due time the straw hat's leaders luck
will run out and run out it did and with
it came a beat down of insane
proportions crocodile finally decided
that play time's over and he verbally
breaks down luffy while unleashing his
true power he finally finishes the
battle by dehydrating his opponent and
even the last ditch heroic wind isn't
enough and luffy gets left for dead
after getting impaled mid-torque this is
one of the biggest defeats i've ever
seen luffy suffer to that point and for
sure it did leave a mark on me we really
get a glimpse of how powerful crocodile
was back then and it sure made me
anticipate the eventual rematch between
the two
next we have madana facing off against
the shinobi alliance
[Applause]
you know he's bound to show up on the
list somewhere modernized dismantling of
the shinobi alliance is not only a
one-man army moment to remember it's
also a big time flex of his powers we
all heard the murmur and the hype before
about this uchiha ancestor and all but
this time he finally shows up to confirm
all those bold claims about his might
what more needs to be said about this
moment besides it being one of the
strongest final villain debuts in battle
shonen yes i intentionally used final
villain because he's the one who fits
the bill the most as an endgame enemy
amongst the contenders he's broken as
hell and he's not shy about showing it
off he then follows this up with some
more insane feats that we love to see
the guy never stops flexing even as he
solos the car gaze after this moment
broken shonen villain galore continues
with utsuru
[Music]
has the honor of giving us one of the
best final fights in shonen anime as
seen in this other video of mine but we
all have to look back at humble
beginnings ah utsuru is right up there
in the gallery of most broken anime
antagonists and the decisive fight
against him is basically a showcase of
how insane this guy is kintoki gets
stomped pretty easily but then the shin
sengumi comes in and gets their ass
kicked as well even kamui and umiboz are
no match for him is there anything
stopping utsuru at this point well we
know by the end of gintama but at that
point it did seem that all hope was lost
it felt like it would take a complete
miracle to even scratch him and that's
how you can tell a villain has done some
very successful flexing on the heroes
of course one of the most broken
villains in anime makes an appearance
well how does father display his godlike
powers make a
yeah sounds insane right but that's just
how father demonstrates the plane he's
at when he finally acquires his godlike
powers for someone who has complete
control over the laws of physics and
chemistry he just showcases his power by
doing the impossible no longer trapped
within the flask father proceeds to
create a second son in the palm of his
hands yeah there could be more uses for
his newfound power but what's a little
gloating and flexing while seated atop
your throne right it's all about sending
a message this is you see and the rules
of the world everything that humanity
has come to know about the world we live
in no longer apply to father he quite
literally has the world in the palm of
his hands and there's no better thing to
do than to let everyone know it that
just shows how crazy powerful father had
become i mean is there anything stopping
him at this point
so what do you think of this list enough
anime villain flexes to keep you
satisfied and hyped for the eventual
showdown against them i'm 100 sure that
i missed some of them out for the sake
of time so if you feel that i failed to
talk about a villain flex moment then
write them down in the comments section
below as always if the video was great
don't forget to hit the like and
subscribe buttons and check out my
channel for more videos i also have an
instagram and a patreon so make sure to
follow and support vinnie tube through
those other avenues don't forget to
check out our sponsors of this video
expressvpn all you have to do is click
the link in the description box or go to
expressvpn.com
vinnie tube for a three month free trial
i hope see you next time more anime
goodness awaits and i want you to be
there
you